[CINEMATIC MUSIC]
During the time of the dinosaurs,
the skies were dominated by flying reptiles
called pterosaurs.
There were over 250 species, and some of them were enormous.
One of the most interesting because they're
the most bizarre are the azhdarchid pterosaurs.
And to try and describe what an azhdarchid pterosaur was
like is very difficult. They stand as tall as giraffes.
They've got heads that may have been 2 meters long,
wingspans of 10 meters.
They're just some of the most bizarre things
to have ever evolved on Earth.
Despite their size, these giants were well adapted for flight.
So why do we think they hunted on the ground?
The azhdarchid's wing is a skin membrane supported entirely
by a super enlarged fourth finger.
This skin membrane extended from the tip
of that giant fourth finger all the way
to the top of the hind leg.
Azhdarchids were supremely adapted for covering
great distance, but they weren't the kind
of animals that were twisting and turning and making
agile movements actually in flight.
This would have made it hard for azhdarchids
to catch other flying animals.
They must have had a different way to hunt.
One of the most prevalent ideas about how azhdarchid pterosaurs
may have fed is by using this bizarre mechanism of foraging
known as skim feeding.
Today birds like black skimmers feed in this way.
It's the most ridiculous way of getting
your food you can imagine.
It is literally pushing your lower jaw through the water
and crashing into your food.
A skimmers neck is built to absorb sudden impacts.
But fossils revealed azhdarchids had none of these adaptations.
In fact, they would almost certainly
break their necks from just the strain
of trying to push their lower jaws through the water.
An azhdarchid had no option.
It must have landed to find food.
But could it really walk fast enough to hunt?
Scientists needed evidence to persuade them
that it could do anything more than just waddle.
That evidence comes from 66 million year old footprints.
The biggest pterosaur track in the world
was made by a walking giant azhdarchid.
And that's not only a cool thing to have,
it tells us an awful lot about how efficient
they were at walking.
These tracks show they held their limbs directly
under their body giving them an upright stance.
Their feet were padded.
And unlike the small pterosaurs, their long legs
gave them an enormous stride.
Although azhdarchids are peculiar looking animals,
they're moving very efficiently.
Azhdarchids combined this very competent terrestrial walking
ability with this massive long stork-like face.
They almost certainly were predators
that walked around reaching down to grab animals.
We have to remember this throat size of this thing
is half a meter wide.
That's about the width of my shoulders.
We would be on the menu for these things
if they were alive today.
Pterosaurs would have been an awe-inspiring sight in the sky,
but these giants were even more impressive and terrifying
on the ground.
[CINEMATIC MUSIC]